I'm just wondering, you know, I'm, I'm, thank you for answering my, because I, I want
to travel to Cuba too. Cuba, Cuba, it's okay to take my machine to, you know, I, I can't
answer that definitively because I've never been to Cuba. I've never tried to take it into
there. You're always dealing whatever you take at your machine into another country. You're
dealing with a human who's making a decision. That's the difficult. You get somebody who didn't
eat lunch today and they could be a little hankerous. So, it's, there is that risk factor. We used
to do, you know, we used to live in Mexico. We used to do a lot of work and bringing this stuff
across the border in Mexico, doing missionary work, and it was always an issue where they were
trying to get us to bribe them. And I, and I felt for them because they probably got paid almost
nothing to do their job and knowing that they're going to make money on bribe. But as the poor
missionary, we didn't have any money to give money for bribes. I just played stupid all the time
to the point where they got so disgusted with me that they let me go by. So,
my, my, my, my fear in any of that is that if they think they could make money off of the
heed that you really did, and they think there's value that they could resell it, I'd hate to have
them confiscated. In this case, what's the solution? Because basically, I want to, you know,
I'm from Europe and I'm traveling, you know, I don't, I don't know. And I just, I want to use my
machine. I want to heal, you know, this. So how long are you going to be this trip?
I'm planning to go to Cuba at least two weeks, but sometimes I'm going to Europe for month.
Well, I don't think you're going to trouble at Europe. We've not had any issues with Europe. We've
had numerous patients from European countries bring their machine back with them, no problem.
So the computer put it into the carry on and the machine can be put into the bigger.
Sure. You could put them a sheet in your carry on, the computer or the carry on. You could put
the ball in your, in your, in your check luggage. And I don't think you're going to even get
questioned. But, but going into Cuba, I think that might, that could be an issue. So,
I just don't know how strict or lax they are with, with whatever you bring into that country. So,
I've not had anybody go there before. Oh, really? Because I'm going to get some, some sunshine,
you know, I'm living in Canada. Why don't you know? Can I go with you? Yes, please, bring your
rice machine. Okay. Thank you.
And you know, we can, I really, really, fine.